こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです。
今日は、ちょっと暑いので
飲み物の紹介をしようと思います。
暑いです。もういやだ
ほんとに暑い、何もしたくない
何なのこの暑さ
訳わかんないんすけど
あああーー
暑いー
喉乾くー
熱中症～
本当に暑い
ずっと晴れだし、もうなんか暑いからやになっちゃう。もう
おいバッ
はい、というわけでみんなはコーラは好きでしょうか？
コーラ
まあ基本的なコーラはこういう真っ黒な色をしたコーラが一般的なのですが
私、このたび
黒くないコーラを発見したでございます。
日本では売ってないんですけど海外から取り寄せることによってそのコーラを自分の手にすることができました。
基本的にコーラといったら黒いイメージがあるんですが本当はコーラは黒いというのは定義的にそうなっているのか？
否でございます。
というわけで私が、今日買ってきたコーラはコチラ
インカコーラです。
冷蔵庫に入れよう
黄金文明の国
インカ帝国にちなんで作られた黄色いコーラ。
私たちの、常識をを超えたゴールデンコーラはアメリカでは大人気
よく冷やしてお飲みください
ということでですね
あの俺は知らねぇよ？
こういうコーラよりゴールデンコーラのほうが人気って言われてるらしいです。
入れてみましょう
黄色いな
普通に黄色いです。
もう、俺の頭の中ではコーラつったらこっちになってるんで
こっちが正しいかっていうとちょっとそれはわからない
それは、実際に飲んでみないとわからないことになるので
ちょっとねー
あの日焼けよ分かる？
完全に色が違うようになっちゃってて
ちょっとマジで日焼けが痛い
プラス熱中症、夏バテ
もうちょっと体調的には最悪
何ですけども
こういうときにね
こう冷たいものをグイッと飲むことによって
一気に復活するんすよ
メンタリティーが
というわけで早速飲んでみましょう。
なるほど...
なるほどなるほどなるほど
なるほどなるほどー
なるほどね
なるほどなるほどなるほど
反応しずらいな
おいしいよ？
でも、コーラっていう味ではねぇな
コーラだけどもコーラではないんですね
んーー
まぁ
何とも言えないな
こっちのがでもライトだ
普通のコーラよりもちょっと飲みやすいですね
おいしい！！
あぁ！
間違いない
コーラうわぁ色がすごくて体に悪そうだからあたし嫌
みたいな人、僕何人か知ってるんですけども
そういう人でもまぁ
インカコーラをこう渡せば
ひょっとしたら騙して飲むことができるかもしれません
はい、というわけで
インカコーラとてもおいしかったです。
TO DAYS　HJIMEN’s POINTプルル３０イェイ！